first of all before we get to the cards
you just told me you went on Fox twice I
did okay and that's great I became the
nominee for the same reason yeah
67 counties in Florida I know what you
know now will tell you I have my issues
with whether or not they're like legit
legit news doesn't matter but
nonetheless right now for the people in
my state believe them to be and
therefore outright use it as a venue
they're definitely not legit news but
the people that's where people are
watching that's what matters sorry I
mean Bill Clinton started that back when
he played the sax on Arsenio Hall
remember it was like this is where the
audience is that's right Obama went on
every show we went on crazy shows two
ferns and the lady with the crazy lips I
mean he did a lot of crazy shows okay
are the competing wings of the
Democratic Party as divided as they seem
or is the rift exaggerated by the media
I think it's exaggerated I mean there's
definitely different perspectives in the
senate caucus for example it goes all
the way from bernie sanders to joe
Manchin but the Senate Democrats have
always been a big tent we're always
gonna argue about issues but in the end
we always do the right thing for working
families and that's where that's where
when it comes to policy they're actually
pretty close all the candidates want to
expand health care it's a question of
how they all want to address climate
change how fast on guns you can go down
the list but it's really emphasis who's
emphasizing what issues and to what
extent is the cultural that cultural
issues playing and some of that is how
you end up seeing who's a progressive
who's considered centrist it's also how
much they take to stick it to the
establishment and that's really about
rhetoric and positioning I'm not sure
the Democrats have always done the right
thing for the working yeah no yeah I
mean repealing you ass compared to the
other side but repealing glass-steagall
wasn't that Clinton wasn't you know it
if you look at I think last week the Des
Moines Iowa Register came out and said
that 40% of folks who chose Bernie
Sanders as the number-one chose Joe
Biden as a number two in in Reverse 37%
of Joe Biden number ones chose Sanders
as a number two so there yeah the white
guys aren't having it so bad
I think it's as much where the party's
divided I think more than anything is
like generational more than it is
ideological now you see the
temperamental difference between you
know a Nancy Pelosi right now who says
hey take a pitchman off the table and
Congresswomen Talib who's like just be
impeached the [ __ ] the attitude
the attitudinal
differences between that younger crop of
activists who've come in just in this
last wave and the older mainstream
moderate there's a big temperamental
difference and on things like
impeachment you could really see that
difference is pretty it's pretty
significant it was a wolf or barking in
the other don't tell me I didn't hear a
wolf barking you know out here that
coyotes they get everywhere
I tell you anybody has a little dog keep
the most to you because that will forget
it what do you think of the presidential
candidate peep-bo accuses judge thank
you so much Twitter will go nuts need a
weird name this year
Budda Budda Budda says like Budapest but
Buddha says what do you think a
president can julep Pete's suggestion
that Democrats packed the Supreme Court
that is what he is suggesting Wow
FDR tried that it didn't work so well
don't know about that I will say as just
the shout out to the course and how
would it work I am here tonight with a
Norman Lear founder American Way
Foundation legend yeah and a great deal
I don't know where you are Norman but a
great deal of that work happens to be
around the you know around the courts in
making sure we get good justices there
those who are not necessarily 100% in
agreement with that but every time but
again do we know how this works I mean
the Supreme Court does not have to be
nine we always think that and then when
I started fussing with it we learned oh
no it couldn't be fifteen it couldn't be
four how would you pack the court you
would have to pass a law to say there
are no it's a piece of legislation it's
that simple I mean it really is that so
it's it's a legislative change I mean I
imagine this would be challenged in
court and so who knows what comes of it
but this is also one of the hallmarks of
progressives versus moderates
progressives are saying the system so
having broken we have to do radical
things do take [ __ ]
I mean so we go from 9 to 15 and then
the night no it's a 27 and we're already
halfway to have been out of republic we
don't need to senator how did you manage
to survive the 28 turn 18 midterms when
many of your moderate colleagues lost
their elections and Trump targeted you
over and over I mean he was unrelenting
we talked about health care early we
went all over the state I listened to
people and the ideas I thought were
bonafide whether they're for my party or
not we took back and tried to put them
into effect and we talked about that and
and I had a pretty strong brand from a
Montanan perspective and the guy was
ruined against it so it was it was just
weird work the people same way Gilliam
or anybody runs for office you go out
there and you bust it for as long and I
would imagine in Montana you feel like
you're already five lengths behind your
competition just because you have the D
next to your name so it's a bit of a
badge of dishonor okay this is a red
state it tends it'll tend to vote
Republican if you don't give them a
reason to vote Democrat we gave you got
a third term governor in his state who's
also who's a third third term in that
red satyrs Democrat right and I think it
goes actually interestingly goes back to
this thing you're talking about it with
Hickenlooper earlier right which is the
what's so ridiculous about the
Hickenlooper question is here's this
multi-millionaire who made millions
dollars by starting these this brewpub
Empire in Colorado the guy's a
capitalist in every bone in his body
right right you you asked him the
question he immediately goes into trying
to figure out I should say this because
somebody should I say capitalist I'm
gonna lose part of the party he's
calculating and trying to figure it out
the reason tester wins wouldn't you
bring that up when I said it at this
level but the reason is that the recent
tester wins in Montana if you go up and
spend time with them is that everybody
in the state looks at him agos he's not
a Democrat not a Republican he's tester
it's right we know the bad guy is and
that's the same reason why the governor
there wins because there's authenticity
to it they're voting for him not for the
party label right yeah authenticity and
if John John brings up a very good point
if you're sitting there as a candidate
thinking gosh well how do I answer this
question because it might cost me votes
over here there you're gonna lose yeah
and I see that
a lot of Democrats already I don't see a
big improvement in how they're how
they're running but one last question
Montana two senators California two
senators that's the way the four five
geniusly thought but we have like 40
million people and you have I know I've
got a million marvelous people
[Applause]
you